hi it's matthew martin from details and
we just finished the raf simon show and
it was all about a futuristic school boy
i love the mix of proportions there was
a lot of boxy coats and jackets mixed
with shorts they were only short
throughout the whole collection which i
thought was a twist for a fall winter
collection
i really loved all the shirt jackets
they actually looked like actual dress
shirts but they were blown up and
exaggerated and he paired them with a
regular dress shirt and tie and i
thought that was a really modern take on
a jacket
all the hats in the show were made of
wool or knits and they looked almost
more like helmets
i love the sweatshirts because they were
this cool degrading print that went from
green to maroon to black the sweaters
were chunky and they were colorful and
they're things that you can easily
incorporate into stuff you already have
he showed everything with sneakers these
really cool trainers they were all these
monochromatic darker colors which is
different usually think of trainers as
being bright and really cheery i like
that these are a little bit moodier
especially for fall winter i thought
that was kind of perfect
for more videos from paris check out
details.com and follow me on twitter at
details matt